thanks everybody thanks everyone for
coming such a great great to have a huge
audience I hope everybody can can see
and participate
first thing is I do have a repository a
github repository with all the course
materials don't feel pressured to be all
hands-on with this stuff but if you want
to you can clone it and run it it's
basically for Jupiter notebooks that I'm
going to go through but I don't really
have any hands-on exercises but as you
know Jupiter notebooks are very hands-on
themselves so you can get in there and
play around a little bit but I'm going
to work through those for during the
course of this tutorial and if you
cloned it previously you might want to
do a git update I did a little bit of
bug fixing and typo correcting during
lunch so there is a little bit of new
stuff in there but otherwise we will we
will get going and in terms of questions
feel free to ask clarifying questions
during the presentation I'm happy to
answer them particularly if it helps you
understand the rest of the material with
90 minutes I'm gonna try to hit sort of
20 minutes per notebook hopefully
leaving us some time at the end but I'm
not terribly good about staying on
schedule so we'll see how that goes
first thing is was this big enough for
everybody probably no loops hold on hold
on good good okay
the URL is my last name slash MC MC
underscore PI data underscore London
underscore 2019 cool
so um as the title suggests I'm gonna
focus on Markov chain Monte Carlo which
is one aspect of Bayesian statistics
namely a numerical method for fitting
Bayesian models but I also noted you
know when I introduced the talk and my
abstract that I don't expect anybody to
have statistical background so I I'm not
gonna focus on theory in this tutorial
but I am gonna start with a little bit
of it just to give those of you who are
very new to Bayes the opportunity to
understand a little bit more about it
but we're gonna focus on the computation
and how to actually specify and fit
those models using the software okay so
I'll skim over a lot of theory at the
bottom of each notebook I've got to
learn more sections which have links to
either books or relevant papers and you
can dig in a little bit yourselves and
I'll be here through Monday if you have
any any questions as well so so you know
starting at the beginning what you know
what is Bayesian analysis how many how
many of you have learned about Bayesian
statistics at some point during college
holy cow okay it's much better in Europe
it seems than in North America because
in North America it typically doesn't
happen I have four college degrees and I
only took a base course in one of them
mostly because they generally weren't
offered so it could be that I'm just old
but so this may be just review for a lot
of you but the definition of Bayesian
statistics I really like is Andrew
gell-mann's
definition practical methods for making
inferences using probability for things
that we observe and about which we wish
to learn so the idea is you know we're
building probability models here and
we're motivated to do that a lot of the
time because they they can be more
robust because they account for general
uncertainty from a number of different
sources so the key is is that all
conclusions from Bayesian analysis are
stated in terms of probabilities so it's
probability in and probability out so
these probability statements are what
you get so a little bit of notation
theta R is anything that's unknown so
this could be you know a regression
parameter
it could be a rate it could be a mean it
could also be something like a predicted
future observation or or missing data
that could also be theta and then we're
conditioning on some data some
observations so theta given Y things we
don't know given what we things that we
do know or at least that we observe all
right and and there's some benefits to
you the user by adopting this approach
one is ease of interpretation so most
people have a pretty good sense of what
probabilities are I currently work with
baseball players and coaches I used to
work with doctors physicians and other
scientists and even though that none of
those folks are statisticians they all
have kind of an idea of what
probabilities are although they can be
certainly be misinterpreted so so you
can really easily interpret these models
or more easily and it makes it a nice
way for summarizing uncertainty and and
it makes it really easy to calculate
various summary statistics all right so
so basically maybe wondering what's the
difference between Bayesian statistics
and classical ones or the sort of
statistics a lot of you may have learned
in in school well with any the things
that are in common first with any
statistical paradigm is that you have
some unknown quantities that you're
interested in learning something about
that's the Thetas that I showed you
previously some data that you've
observed and and hopefully have
information about the things that you
don't know and then we link those
together with with a model of some kind
and that model can be anything from you
know a statistical test all the way to a
regression model or a machine learning
model and but that's where the
similarity ends so if you're a
frequentist like Ronald Fisher here you
you you view the world in a slightly
particularly well in a particular way so
the idea with if you're a frequentist
you you you consider your data to be
random that they were generated by
random processes and each time you go
out and observe the world you'll get
different values and
so that's the thing that we're gonna
model and then your model parameters or
your unknowns are the things that are
fixed so they're fixed and we condition
on them so this is kind of how
frequences thinks probability of your
data given given some values of
parameters which are unknown and so if
you're a frequentist what you do is you
spend most your time coming up with
estimators for things so estimators for
those unknown quantities and so for
example a simple example is binomial
proportions right so the example here if
your estimated Fira a if you're
interested in global health or or
disease something like autism spectrum
disorder you may want to know the
prevalence in the population right the
proportion of people in the population
with that with that disease and so you
you might observe a certain number of
them N and Y of them have the disease
and so you estimate a proportion and and
you know it's an intuitive way to
calculate that but there's a reason that
you choose this particular estimator
it's got properties right it's you know
unbiased or minimum variance or various
other things
so every time you have a new problem you
got to come up with different estimators
for things if you're a Bayesian like Tom
spaced you sort of see the world
differently you view the data as being
fixed they may have been generated by a
random process but once you've collected
them or observed them they're static
right every time you open your notebook
the same data are written down they
don't change and so because they've been
observed we're gonna we're gonna
condition on those the model parameters
or any sort of unknowns that you're
interested in they may not be random
they may be fixed in principle but what
we do is we use probability to
characterize our uncertainty in those
values so they're sort of random in that
sense in that in that we don't know the
values of them and so this is the same
quantity that showed you above
probability of the unknowns given given
the data
so sometimes bate and in the Pat more in
the past Bayesian inference is referred
to as inverse probability because you're
reasoning from observe
two parameters were from effects to
causes okay and and Bayesian is the nice
thing about other nice thing about being
Bayesian z-- is that you don't have to
be good at coming up with estimators for
things cuz there's only one estimator in
Bayesian statistics and that's base
formula so here's my obligatory equation
showing Bayes formula okay and so the
thing that we're interested in over on
your left is the posterior probability
that I've showed you already and the way
that we get that is we combine some
information from our data in terms of
what we call a statistical likelihood
and notice this this is essentially what
frequencies to use right and some
estimate of what we know about the
unknowns before we collected the data
that we call this a prior so we have the
world before we did our experiment or
observe some data we add data to it and
then we update what we know about those
unknowns about theta and then there's
this pesky normalizing constant which
causes all sorts of problems that will
come up talked about a little bit more
later
okay so easiest way to demonstrate some
of this is with a simple example so I'm
gonna you know go about introducing both
Bayesian inference and PI MC using a
relatively simple example so a
statistical hypothesis right sort of
thing you'd get in classical statistical
applications and and in a classical
sense what you would do is you'd write
you'd come up with a hypothesis that
you're interested in and then some
alternative to that of null hypothesis
essentially the world without that
effect that you're trying to estimate
and and you you you would typically come
up with some sort of test or test
statistic that would determine whether
or not you can abandon that know and
perhaps in favor of your alternative and
you know there the reason some people
become Bayesian z-- is they don't really
like that approach we're not always
trying to test things necessarily but we
shoehorn things into statistical tests
it involves a lot of arbitrary decisions
like which test to use which null
hypothesis to test sometimes those null
hypotheses are really trivial and easy
to reject and then the level at which we
declare something to be quote-unquote so
you
again which causes all sorts of problems
as you may have noticed in some of the
statistical literature what we're going
to do instead with a Bayesian approach
is still evaluate hypotheses not
necessarily test them but we're gonna
use an estimation right we don't just
want to know is an effect present or is
something significant we want to know
how big it is how significant it is and
so what we're gonna do instead is build
a model estimate the things we don't
know and then as a bonus come up with
estimates of uncertainty around that
okay and the case study I'm going to use
here is this example pops up a couple
different times in Andrew gell-mann's
books this is a radon contamination
study this is some data collected by the
United States Environmental Protection
Agency and they go around measuring
radon in different places radon is a the
number one cause of non smoking related
lung cancer and it kind of seeps into
your house through the ground depending
on where you live our house in Nashville
Tennessee has radon contamination so
they've got you know plastic all over
the basement and a little fan that blows
it all out into my neighbor's yard and
and so you want to know whether or not
these levels are dangerous or not
and so what the reason they collect this
data is to try to you know maybe
identify areas in different locations
that might be more or less prone to this
sort of contamination so it's a big data
set I'm not gonna use all of it oh if
you are running this by the way I've got
all of my notebooks rendered and with
all of the output so you may want to
clear them all output there we go
and what I'm gonna do I'm gonna not
gonna dig in too much right now about
the PI MC side of things I'm gonna just
show this to you on a high level to give
you an idea of how it works and then in
other notebooks I'm gonna go in and a
little bit more depth and talk about
this stuff so so here's the radon data
and we're gonna be interested in a
couple of so we're gonna take one
particular County in the state of
Minnesota arbitrarily and the the level
of radon contamination the
is thought to be you know worrisome is
according to the US EPA is 4 picoCuries
per liter I guess that is and so we want
to know you we might want to know say
you're an official in Hennepin County
which is we're gonna look at here
whether the mean radon value for the
county is greater than this four level
and and then maybe the probability that
any randomly chosen household in that
county would be subject to that level
okay so I'm just this is just pulling
out that data so this is what it looks
like we're gonna log transform it right
these are positive quantities levels of
radon and so it's sometimes helpful to
transform things onto the real wine
which is what we're doing here so we can
use things like normal distributions
makes our life easier okay and we want
to know and so log four is right around
here so it looks pretty close to the
mean but there's you know maybe some
uncertainty about that okay all right so
what we're gonna do is follow the
Bayesian workflow and the Bayesian
workflow is really kind of a three-step
process there's lots of sub steps to
each of them but in general what you do
first is you specify a probability model
right so base for me that I showed you
before you want to put everything that
you care about that's relevant to the
problem at hand into that form and
typically what that involves is throwing
a probability distribution around
everything that's observed or unknown
and then relating those to one another
probabilistically okay so so you're
making some choices about which sampling
distribution the data have right so I
already hinted at that here right this
looks sort of normally distributed so I
might use a normal likelihood that's the
data that's the information and then
what form best describes our uncertainty
and the unknown parameters in this case
write the mean the standard deviation
and things like that
okay those are those are the two most
important things then once you do all
that you turn Bayes crank right you take
priors and likelihoods and you turn them
into posteriors you calculate a
posterior distribution and that can be
tricky they're very hard to calculate
analytically even though we have nice
closed-form equation it's not always
easy to calculate that as we'll see but
the good news is once you have a
posterior you have everything you need
to do your magic right you can calculate
point estimates for things you
automatically get things like credible
intervals other measures of uncertainty
for free because you have entire
distributions right remember our output
is all going to be entire probability
distributions and then the third step is
model checking and you know this is
common to all statistical paradigms or
both statistical paradigms but it's
particularly important in Bayes because
this is all model-based inference and
it's really easy to get a result that
looks okay but is entirely meaningless
and so going back and checking the model
is very important what do I mean by
checking well if we're using MCMC like
we're gonna do did MCMC work just sort
of mechanically did it work did you code
your algorithm right does the model fit
the data no there should be some
correspondence between the data and
things that's predicted by the model are
the conclusions reasonable and
sensitivity of your results to some of
the choices you make right I've told you
you had to make choices about sampling
distributions and prior distributions
and things like that so it's good to go
back in there and check okay all right
so what's our probability model well
like I've said twice now we're gonna use
a normal distribution for our our
sampling distribution because log radon
looks approximately normal again we can
go back and check this they're not
written in stone so if that's our model
then we have kind of two unknowns that
are clear here I mean and a standard
deviation two parameters define the
normal distribution so we've got to make
choices about priors how do we choose
priors well it depends on the what what
is the underlying parameter looks like
right is it something that's discrete or
continuous what's the support of the
variable can I take negative values does
it take really big values and really
small values all those sorts of things
and of course you may have information
that is relevant to
the problem at hand outside of what
you've observed in your data set that
you may want to incorporate some
consider this a weakness of Bayes that
makes it less objective typically it's a
strength when you particularly when
using observational data sets you want
to bring everything into play that you
possibly can to get the best possible
answer and then sometimes includes prior
information but you can ignore all that
and create priors that are I won't call
them uninformative though they sometimes
are at least diffuse priors sums the
ones that don't have a lot of influence
relative to the data set on the
posterior distribution so in this case
I'm going to choose a for the mean a
normal distribution centered on zero
with a standard deviation of 10 so it's
a so it's a normal distribution but it's
a really really wide one relative to our
our observations and then for the
standard deviation it's got to be
positive so you can choose things like a
gamma distribution or 1/2 all sorts of
half distributions half normal half
caoxi being in half being the positive
half I'm gonna choose a uniform with the
meet the minimum being zero because it
has to be positive and then I pick some
value that I know is way too big that
will never be bigger than all you want
the most important thing is not to
exclude areas of the parameter space
that could potentially be the true value
because then you're stuck once you've
set something a probability to 0 anytime
you multiply something by 0 it's always
0 so we got to make sure we don't do
that make that mistake so those are my
choices
and then from PI MC I'm gonna import the
things that I need so namely a model I
need a model to keep things in and some
distributions so PI MC is a very
high-level language means that I'm
basically building models in code looks
a lot like you would be if you were
writing it down on a whiteboard and
that's kind of the model that we've
we've chosen here so I'm gonna take a
normal in a uniform
I'm gonna instantiate a model and put it
inside of a context manager so the with
statements context manager and what this
will do is it will automatically add
anything inside that context manager to
the model so you don't have to have all
these add statements which are happening
under the hood
right so I have a model I'm gonna call
it radon model so I can open it up later
and add more things to it and then
here's my normal
because we're in Jupiter we can use
Greek letters which are cool
so with mute there's mune Sigma looks
again just like the whiteboard all right
so those are the first elements and then
we need our likelihood which is normal
and the mean is going to be our mu that
we just defined here and standard
deviation will be the Sigma there and
actually we updated we updated the API
to be a little bit more consistent so
not half Greek half non-greek it's all
Greek now so mu and Sigma it'll still
work with SD but as well update it while
I'm here okay there's our model it's
essentially done
I picked a simple model intentionally
and then now we hit the magic inference
button which in this case will run MCMC
so all I've got to do is run sample I'm
gonna sample for a thousand iterations
I'm gonna tune it for a thousand
iteration so it's gonna optimize the
running of the MCMC algorithm and it's
gonna run a sample two chains in on two
cores I've got my little pixel book here
that's only got two physical cores and
so I'm gonna make use of both of them
and then we can look at the answer and
so here's here's the posterior
distribution of the mean and and because
we have this distribution so this
signifies how much we know about that
mean if I if there were millions of
households in Hennepin County and I and
I sampled from all of them as that
information gets really strong that will
collapse to essentially a point
probability right you'd be entirely sure
of what that value is but we do have
some residual uncertainty here so it's a
mean of 1.3 again log scale the log four
is 1.3 9 roughly and so we can say nice
things like this that there's a 16%
chance that the true mean is above the
critical value and 83% chance that it's
less okay and then of course we want to
make a prediction right what if we take
a
but if a new house is built in Hanneman
county what's its risk of having radon
contamination above that level so we can
do something called posterior predictive
sampling so this is where we combine the
residual uncertainty from our estimation
and the stochastic uncertainty of just
you know random chance sampling and to
make a prediction that combines both of
those so it's it's essentially a more
robust than just picking the mean for
example so I'm going to draw a thousand
samples and the probability that a given
household will have that valent of value
greater than four will be point four six
which is much bigger than 0.16 right so
two different questions is the mean
greater than four or one point three
nine and what's the probability of my
house will have contamination okay all
right that's the idea simple example
I forgot the model checking part so
let's talk about model checking how do
we know that this models any good it
looks good
it seems it provides sensible results I
think but how do we know well the
simplest way and an effective way of
doing that is to use some of those
posterior predictive checks because what
the posterior predictive sampling is
going to do is it's going to essentially
generate data from my model right it's
gonna generate new data and so a
sensible thing to do is to generate lots
of fake data and compare your fake data
to the real data and if the real data
looks kind of like your fake data then
it probably says your model is okay
right this model could have been the
true generating model that's kind of
what we're after and so that's we're
gonna do here so I've taken you know
that you essentially have 500 estimates
so I'm gonna come up with 500
probabilities of a new house having
radon contamination above log four so
that's represented by the histogram and
then here's the empirical one which is
the red line your posterior predictive
test could be a lot of different things
talk about that later when I get into
model checking in more depth okay and so
boom if we be concerned if the data were
way out in the tails right then we there
would be a lack of fit in our model we
would say there
the other thing prior sensitivity I
picked you know a normal for the mean
and a uniform for the standard deviation
and I picked those because I've been
doing bass for decade or so but they're
subjective choices essentially so I'm
gonna go in and pick different things so
I'm gonna pick off what we call a flat
prior from you so it's equally probable
from negative infinity to positive
infinity so it's not even a proper prior
yet somehow we're gonna get a proper
posterior and I pick a half Koshi
distribution the co she's got really
thick tail it's like a normal
distribution it's got really thick tails
also arbitrary but at least different
and I'ma leave Nora I'm gonna leave the
distribution normal I think that's
pretty reasonable and I'm gonna do that
again run the model again here's the
estimate fifteen point seven here's what
it was before which was what sixteen
points something right sixteen point two
so they're you know the credible
intervals are the same etc so it not
entirely in sensitive to our choices for
priors that's kind of your intro to
Bayes this quick can flip over to the MC
MC 1 which is ostensibly what this
tutorial is about so we've just used MC
MC now I'm gonna dig in a little bit
tell you a little bit about what MC MC
does how to do it we're gonna this
notebook contains an MC MC sampler coded
by hand again to give you an idea of
kind of how it works so that second step
of Bayesian inference which has
calculated posterior you just literally
go in there and calculate it like it was
easy it's not easy and that's one of the
reasons that you know Bayes hasn't been
taught widely in schools until I guess
until recently they're hard to calculate
and they typically require numerical
method
and the reason is is you know while it's
easy to talk about turning the bass
crank and adding prior information to
likelihood to get a posterior in order
for that posterior to itself be a
probability distribution you've got a
you've got to normalize it right you've
got to make sure that it integrates to
one so you've got to have this
normalizing constant here probability of
Y the probability of the data what is
that it's sometimes called the model
evidence but it's the marginal
likelihood and the reason it's marginal
is you marginalize over all of the
parameters so you integrate out the
parameters which is easy if you have one
parameter I can do one dimensional
integration I used to be able to do two
back in when I was taking calculus in
university I can't do three and most of
you can't either probably so and and the
models I typically use will have ten or
hundreds of parameters so so you can't
you can't just calculate Bayes in closed
form except for some special cases that
we won't talk about here most of the
time you've got to do some sort of
approximation and there's lots of
approximations you can do a brute-force
optimization which will just give you
the posterior modes some people are
happy with that that solves some
people's problems
some people use methods called
variational inference where you take
another distribution that's easy to deal
with and you warp it until it kind of
looks like the posterior and you run
with that and that has its own benefits
and limitations what we're going to use
is a sampling based approach because the
posterior distribution is unknown it's
also hard to sample from it directly
right we could if we want to do Monte
Carlo you you would take samples from
your distribution over and over and over
again and then you can integrate and do
all sorts of things but you can't even
sample from it directly because it's
form as is unknown so if we can't take
independent samples what if we could
take dependent samples turns out we can
take dependent samples and that's what
Markov chain Monte Carlo does it is a
sampling method that generates a Markov
chain and for those of you unfamiliar
with Markov chains what that is
something called a stochastic process
and a stochastic process is just an
indexed set of random variables
typically indexed by T sometimes it's
time right X 1 X 2 X 3 etc but the
important thing is is that it's got a
particular pattern of dependence what
this says is that the probability of x
at t plus 1 given X at T X of t minus 1
all the way back to X of 0 is the same
as the probability of X of T plus 1
given just X of T the current value so
in other words the history doesn't
matter or if it doesn't matter it's kind
of wrapped up in the current value ok so
it's almost independent right its
independent of everything else except
this last or current value right so if
you play monopoly a monopoly game is a
Markov chain right probability of being
on Park Place in the next turn there's
only conditional where you are now it
doesn't matter that you were you know in
jail two turns ago or something like
that right Markov chains so but not any
Markov chain not just any Markov chain
will do you have to have a Markov chain
with specific values so one part of one
part of that emcee is Markov chain Monte
Carlo part is the sampling part and it's
got a sample with a particular pattern
one is is that it has to be reversible
all right you can show that you know
because of this Markovian property you
actually invoke bayes theorem to show
that you know probability of getting
from X going backward X of T given X of
T plus 1 you can solve that through
Bayes formula as well and you can
rearrange it to look like this so
probably Y given X or X given Y is the
transition colonel so it shows how
things move from X to Y and then pi PI X
and Piatt Y pi is the underlying
distribution the posterior distribution
that you're interested in if the Markov
chain that you generate satisfies this
it's called detailed balance equation or
reversibility then if you sample from
this as n goes to infinity you will get
samples that are indistinguishable from
the true underlying posterior
distribution the PI here ok so I I
wrapped up sort of you know two classes
in Bayesian inference in like 10 seconds
just then again I'm not gonna dig deeply
into the theory but this is kind of what
has to happen ok you just have to trust
at this point we're going to come up
with Markov chains that obey detail
balance if we do that and we sample from
them then we will get a Markov chain
that converges to the true posterior
distribution ok that's kind of the
punchline and there is a number of
algorithms that satisfy this that
generates such Markov chains so there is
an a algorithm called MCMC right it's a
class of algorithms right there's no
birds called bird there's just Robbins
and kites and other things right same
idea the sort of most general most
popular algorithm I guess is something
called metropolis Hastings I'm gonna go
through metropolis Hastings right now
and kind of give you an idea of how this
works it's a pretty straightforward
algorithm actually the idea here is that
you initialize the parameters of your
model arbitrarily and you propose new
values and the way you propose new
values is through some sort of proposal
distribution so we have some auxiliary
distribution that is easy to sample from
and work with a normal distribution will
do something like that you propose a new
value you evaluate its acceptance we'll
see how to do that in a second if it's
acceptable we keep it and we add it to
our sample if it's not we revert to the
current value we actually take another
copy of the current value then we go
back and do it again we'll propose a new
one
given the current value evaluate it
accept it or reject it and so on so in
principle very simple thing to do how do
we accept it how do we evaluate it
excuse me we evaluate it based on the
probability of the posterior
distribution the log probability under
the new value
versus what it currently is under the
current value so here's my new value
does it improve the posterior
probability or not if it does we always
take it if we don't we take it with some
probability and that probability is
related approximately to the ratio of
the probabilities of new versus old okay
so if we made things better we keep it
if we didn't well we might keep it okay
so we don't always want to move to
higher probability we want to explore
the entire distribution the tails the
peak and everything okay so we have this
acceptance ratio here so the the
algorithm again just as I said before
have some theta prime some candidate
generate a uniform random number if it's
less than that ratio we accept it
otherwise we reject it right in terms of
proposal distributions they can be
anything but you can make choices that
make your life harder or easier the the
easiest one to implement is something
called a random walk proposal where you
pick a symmetric distribution usually a
normal distribution centered on the
current value and then you sample from
it so you'll take a jump you'll accept
it or reject it if you accept it
your next value will you again Center a
normal distribution on that current
value and you take a jump from there
okay so it's very easy to implement
right there just you're taking centered
random deviates and we're adding them
iteratively to the current value okay
and then an important consideration here
is you know how why do we make that
proposal distribution right if we take
big jumps that has consequences versus
taking very little jumps as we'll see in
a second all right so I'll pick another
different but also simple example this
is a linear regression simple linear
regression so we're trying to estimate
the price of houses as a function of age
okay so so our expected value is a
linear function of age and the error the
or the sampling distribution is going to
be normal
so our expected value will be an
intercept plus a slope times the age and
then some value tau will be the standard
deviation of that so there's the data
hope new notebook clear the output here
we go alright so that's what it looks
like old hoses are bad apparently so
we're expecting some linear decrease
here I'm not saying that the best model
is just a model all right and so I'm
doing this by hand here not using PI MC
so what I need is a a way of evaluating
proposals right and I said that the way
of doing that is via the joint posterior
distribution so I'm gonna take the total
posterior on the log scale most you
probably know it's easier to work within
logarithms a lot of time because adding
and subtracting are more stable than
multiplying and dividing so these are
going to be log log normals I've gone
into sigh PI stats here and pulled out
gamma and normal because those are going
to be the distributions I'm going to use
I'm gonna put normal priors on the
regression parameters alpha and beta
beta naught and beta 1 sorry I'm a I'm a
switch notation on you without warning
just to just to warn you and and then
the prior on the standard deviation is
going to be a gamma and I'm choosing a
gamma because it's positive it's always
going to be positive valued and it can
have kind of nice long tails on it as
well so all right so here's my prior on
the intercept here's my prior on the
slope here's my prior on the standard
deviation I just add them up and then I
calculate mu and I also add the
likelihood given those values of mu and
tau okay and so for any given value of
the parameters a B and T and the data I
can calculate the log posterior and then
what my algorithm is going to do is just
one function here is it's going to have
initial values and initial values of
this for each of the parameters and one
by one so it's going to be a three-step
loop here one for each parameter it's
gonna
propose new values for that parameter
accepted or reject it move on to the
next parameter and so one loop will be
going through all of the all three
parameter values so for J and range and
params I do this this isn't a very
general MCMC algorithm here because I've
hard coded you know if if J is is equal
to two so if it's the standard deviation
I'm only going to propose positive
values because I know the standard
deviation can't be negative insert that
value in here calculate the posterior
here's the acceptance rate it's on the
log scale so I'm subtracting and not
dividing there's my uniform random
variate there's what happens if I accept
it there's what happen if I reject it
okay so it's pretty pretty
straightforward okay I'm gonna run this
for 5,000 iterations and I'm gonna pick
a pretty small proposal variance so that
point zero zero one is the standard
deviation of the proposal distribution
and I gave away the punchline here by
telling you so the acceptance rate is
very high
over 90% which sounds good accepting
seems good doesn't it we like to be
accepted but it's bad if you're an MC MC
algorithm because your proposals look
like this right so if you pick a really
tiny scale parameter for your proposals
it's gonna take really tiny little steps
and they'll all get accepted everybody
will be happy except it'll take you a
really long time to cover the posterior
distribution right it's not gonna
doesn't do a good job of exploring the
parameter space and so it'll look like
that and that's not good
all right let's make a big then let's
pick a standard deviation of 20
one percent point zero zero eight
percent yeah very small also not good
okay so what's happening here lots of
rejections right remember what happens
if you don't accept you make a copy of
the current values so these flat lines
are just it's taking really big jumps
way off into the tails of the posterior
and that has a really low acceptance
probability so you want some somewhere
in between right you want to do some
exploration but not all exploration you
do want to characterize the distribution
itself so the key here is to tune it
right so it's pretty easy here to tune
the algorithm to have a scale parameter
that is beneficial what do we tune it to
well work has been done to show that for
an metropolis Hastings algorithm the
optimal acceptance rate is point two
three four so somewhere between twenty
and fifty percent usually works okay and
so that's we're gonna do here so it's
exactly the same algorithm except I've
added some logic in here about every how
so what's gonna happen every hundred
iterations we're going to keep track of
acceptances and rejections and if the
rate is less than twenty percent I'm
gonna shrink the proposal standard
deviation by ten percent and if it's
greater than forty percent I'm gonna
make it bigger by ten percent and so
over time it'll narrow down so let's run
that so it's running it for ten thousand
iterations tuning it for five thousand
you don't want to you don't want to use
those tuning values there you actually
violate the detailed balance equation
when you do this tuning so we're just
using that to set things up and we'll
take the last five thousand now now
we're in business around thirty percent
twenty five to thirty percent and so if
we look at these plots a lot better
these this still needs a bit of work but
that's looking for the fuzzy caterpillar
so we're looking for like a homogeneous
you know we don't want it having any
sort of trend associated with it
stationary they call it okay that's the
kind of thing we're looking for
we'll get into model checking a little
bit later and then again the nice thing
is we can draw from that posterior
distribution so this this is a draw of
fifty-fifty regression lines so kind of
give you an idea of the uncertainty in
those regression lines okay that's the
idea
all right so that that's sort of to give
you an intuition of MCMC we don't
typically use metropolis algorithms very
much anymore it's not state-of-the-art
anymore the problem with it is it
doesn't work very well for most problems
and the reason is is that as as your
models get larger and more interesting
metropolis Hastings has a really hard
time exploring the posterior
distribution the geometry gets too crazy
for it and and maybe not unexpected
right this is a pretty naive random walk
algorithm you shouldn't expect too much
from it it doesn't take much to trip it
up in fact so this is from a paper from
Hoffman and Gelman this is a complex but
simple model this is a link it's like a
10,000 dimensional multivariate normal
so a multivariate normal with K equals a
thousand we'll say it's a thousand and
these are marked to marginal to
arbitrarily chosen marginal values from
that so the truth oops the truth looks
like this independent right it's just a
correlated normal distribution
metropolis Hastings gets you that Gibbs
sampling which is a slightly more
efficient version of metropolis Hastings
gets you that which is better but we
don't that's not the same right so there
will get a biased result so we want a
better algorithm so what the heck is
nuts this is what we're gonna do next
nuts looks pretty good doesn't it that's
what we want so we want a less naive
algorithm and in this case what that
means is we're gonna use some
information from the model itself to
guide our proposals and make them better
twenty three percent isn't you know it's
not good really wastes a lot of
computation and it often doesn't get you
where you want to go
what we really want to do when we're
doing MCMC is explore something called
the typical set and the typical set is
in a model the area with most of the
probability underneath it which sounds
pretty simple but it's it's a so there's
some subtleties associated with with it
most of the probability density is
located near the mode right it's near
the peak but as you add dimensions that
peak has less and less volume so as you
add if you think about a section of a
line and at just some arbitrary piece in
the middle and you turn that line into a
square and that's square into a cube the
proportion that's occupied by that
center piece gets smaller and smaller
and smaller until when you have hundreds
of parameters there really isn't any
volume left near the middle near the you
know the posterior near the mean and or
the mode and so it's really hard
you can't just find the middle find the
mode and start sampling it doesn't work
that way and so what we're going to do
instead is again use auxiliary variables
but we're gonna use it in a different
way what we're gonna do is we're gonna
explore the form of the posterior
distribution by simulating Hamiltonian
dynamics how many people here are
physicists you know all about
Hamiltonian dynamics right so how so
we're gonna essentially treat the
posterior distribution like a skateboard
park right and you're a skate bird your
point is a skateboarder and you're gonna
push the skateboarder down and what's
gonna happen right she's gonna follow
the contours of the skateboard park and
at some point you're gonna tell the
skateboarder to stop and that's gonna be
your new proposal and then you're gonna
push the skateboarder again and they're
gonna weave around and then they're
gonna stop at some point and that'll be
your next point and so there you're
gonna get samples from your posterior
distribution and you're gonna go to
places with high or low probability by
simply climbing gradients so that's the
idea here so we were gonna instead
simulate Hamiltonian dynamics so the
Hamiltonian is just this it's it's
essentially saying that the total energy
of your system is just your potential
plus your kinetic energy right or your
position and
your velocity and so your position will
be the point that you're interested in
and the velocity will be just an
auxiliary variable that we throw away
okay and that's kind of the idea so what
we're doing now is simulating
Hamiltonian dynamics so we're gonna
change position or change a position
will change our velocity and so on and
but the hard part here now right two
hard things one the Hamiltonian
continuous system and it's hard to do
continuous things on computers right
we've got to discretize this and then
the other things are these derivatives
it's hard to calculate derivatives not
as hard as integrating as it turns out
but it's hard to calculate derivatives
but as you know we have lots of cool
software now that does this for us
automatically tensor flow and torch and
things like that PI MC uses Theano
or at least it does for the time being
to do this for us so we built pi MC 3 on
top of Theano
and it does all of this automatic
differentiation for us so that part of
it is easy now and and then the what was
the other part Oh the continuous versus
the discretization comes from our
algorithm so this is what so the the
algorithm itself is called Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo or hybrid Monte Carlo
sometimes called created by Radford Neel
really good paper from 1993 if you want
to know more about it and the the core
of it is the algorithm that does the
integration of the Hamiltonian so what
it does is it essentially takes a 1/2
step for position takes another half
step for velocity and then another half
step for position so it takes these
little half steps and discretize is if
you take steps it's kind of like large
and small proposals in metropolis
Hastings if you take really small steps
that you'll get a nice almost continuous
line but it won't be very efficient if
you take really big steps you it doesn't
become a very good you know your track
your your integration isn't very true so
there is some optimization to be done
there and then because we're doing this
discretization of a continuous system we
act
do you have to do an accept reject at
the end if we were able to do things
continuously we wouldn't have to
but now our acceptance rates are more
like 8090 percent rather than twenty
okay so the HMC algorithm also
relatively simple we now now what we do
is we sample a velocity so how hard are
we going to push the skateboarder down
the hill or up the hill okay we're gonna
give it a flick it in one direction
that'll give us some momentum and and
then we perform a bunch of these
leapfrog steps and at some point we stop
and we accept to reject that point and
then we do it again okay all right and
so one of the IMC developers Colin
Carroll has a nice it's really hard to
illustrate this stuff using PI MC cuz
everything gets kind of black boxed so
I'm gonna give the idea about what some
of this stuff looks like so he's got a
package called mini MC that uses a
really nice package called autograph
that just does automatic differentiation
and it allow us to track things a little
bit so let's say we have our posterior
distribution looks like this it's a
normal mixture of three different normal
distributions normal bivariate normal
distributions so again relatively simple
but metropolis would have a really hard
time with this what would happen is it
would find one of the peaks and it would
just stay there
and it wouldn't be able to jump across
those areas of low probability okay and
so our leapfrog integration is encoded
here in this leapfrog function inside of
mini MC and all it needs are step sizes
and a momentum so we're gonna do a bunch
of leapfrog steps so we're not doing
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo yet this is just
to show you what leapfrog integration
looks like and do three different
examples Colin has a really nice blog
post that I've listed at the bottom that
goes into this stuff so these are three
sort of candidate leap frogs it's it's
just one it's just being a skateboarder
it's not doing any sampling and you can
see that it does a little bit of
everything
you can get it if you give it a little
bit of momentum it'll just end up and
really do a really good job of
characterizing one peak but then you can
also move between Peaks and so on right
it doesn't get stuck in the same way
that metropolis would with Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo we use that leapfrog
integration but we have to do something
slightly a little bit more what we have
to do is we have to decide when to stop
all right you can't just keep
skateboarding around forever we've got
to do some sampling and you don't want
those to be either too small or too big
so there's a choice there with how long
you wait before you take a sample and so
if we do that this is going to show
three different three different path
lengths and you can see if you choose
different path lengths you end up
sampling a little bit differently and
the first one they're very short so they
generally stay in one place
whereas path length of four it starts
moving between the peaks pretty nicely
okay all right that's kind of the idea
again this is just skimming over a lot
of it this is hopefully to give you a
little bit of an intuition as to how
this works so let's move on to the third
one which is now we're going to get a
little bit more into PI MC and how we
build models in PI MC and and some of
the strategies that we'll need for doing
that okay so I'm see what it does is it
gives you the building blocks to
construct Bayesian models arbitrary
Bayesian models so you'll sometimes find
packages that do very specific kinds of
models like generalized linear models
with time see any model you write down
you should be able to build and fit and
and the way that we do that is give you
very general building blocks so there
are really three different blocks that
you need one are stochastic random
variables as the name implies they're
essentially probability distributions
with some other attributes deterministic
variables so sometimes we have to
combine or transform things to make them
fit our problem and so we have to do
these deterministic transformations and
we've got to account for that in the
model as well and then something called
a factor
excuse me factor potential which I'll
tell you about in justice
second and I'll use yet again a
different example so you don't get bored
oh hold on this is a we use this a lot
in pi MC this is a time series data set
of coal mining disasters in the UK so
going back to 1851 so I don't know what
what merits being labeled to disaster I
guess a collapse of a mine or something
like that and so these are just counts
annual counts of when coal mining
disasters happen and you can see it's an
interesting time series because they
tend to be higher at the beginning and
then lower towards the end so somewhere
in the middle somewhere in there maybe
something happened right there could
have been changes in regulations laws
there could be technological advances
who knows and so what we're gonna do
here is fit what's called a change point
model so the nice thing about being
Bayesian is that if there's anything you
don't know about the model even if it's
a nuisance parameter what you do is you
put a prior on and add it to the model
and estimate it just like everything
else and so just because we don't know
you know maybe if you're an expert on
the history of coal mining you can tell
me that in you know 1889 such-and-such
happened but we don't know that
so it's an unknown to us we're gonna add
it to the model so we're gonna ask me
three things here what the mean number
of disasters was before a particular
point in time that's unknown the mean
afterwards and then where that change
point is so three random quantities hi
the number of Mines oh I see so you
think just because we have let fewer
mines yeah it could be
yes we're gonna assume that they're the
same that's my assumption for today yeah
because yeah the rate could stay the
same and we just have a few no yep yeah
you would think there'd be fewer coal
mines over time although maybe not over
at this timescale but who knows good
question we're gonna assume that they're
the same because but that will affect
what the underlying rate would be so
under that assumption what we're gonna
do so we got what do we have to do we
got to follow our Bayesian three-step
process so our probability model we need
a sampling distribution and we need a
priors for things that we don't know our
sampling distribution I'm going to
choose as Poisson so Poisson
distribution is just essentially a model
for counts it's a very simple model it's
got one parameter that characterizes the
mean and the variance so as the mean
increases the variance increases often
used to model counts although sometimes
not very robustly and then the unknowns
are going to be the two rates before and
after and the change point so we'll need
three priors here so what we're going to
say is there's going to be two values
lambda 1 and lambda 2 and it's going to
be lambda 1 if the Year T is less than
tau which is our change point and lambda
2 otherwise okay and what I'm gonna do
is put gamma priors on the two lambdas
because they're rights they have to be
positive
just like we chose a gamma before when
we were talking about standard deviation
and then tau is gonna just be uniform
all right I mean we can see that looking
at the data that there's the change
points somewhere there in the middle but
we're not supposed to look at the data
before we do this right otherwise that's
prior information but so I'm gonna
pretend I didn't look at the data and
just say that it's uniform okay all
right so how does this get implemented
well all these stochastic variables all
the unknowns in your model will be
characterized by a class an underlying
class called free RV so these are free
rent free to vary
random variables and what they
essentially are are probability
distributions tied to that are able to
calculate log probabilities given
current parameters and and they're able
to draw random samples from them as well
and each free random variable will
always be associated with a model okay
so they all belong to models the main
way that we create stochastic random
variables is using what I will call the
automatic method which means that the
probability distributions already been
defined and associated with that free
random variable so we can go in and
customize this but most of the time
you're going to do it this way or you're
gonna say I need a uniform prior for
this random variable so I'm just going
to import uniform from PIME c3 and
parameterize it as I need it so this
will create a free random variable
object and it will associate it with
this model alright and in a similar
fashion we're going to do the same with
the Exponential's alright so we have
three free random variables prime C
includes most of the probability
distributions that you would want but
it's easy to add custom ones if you need
to I'll show you how to do that in just
a second some of the important
attributes that it will have is a D type
right because you're gonna sample you're
gonna do things slightly differently if
you're a continuous random variable
versus a discrete one it will have
default values so if you are in it don't
want to initialize your random variables
before you start your MCMC it will pick
the median mean or mode depending on
what is available to initialize the map
if you don't want if you just want to
use an exponential random variable and
not have it associated with a model it's
got a class method called dist that
strips away all the PI MC machinery and
just gives you an exponential that you
can go in and sample from so I can go in
here and go random size equals thousand
and I'll get a thousand exponential
variables not associated with the model
if I did exponential one like so I will
get an index error says no model on the
contact stack right so it's got to be in
a model context for you to use it but
what if what if you either don't like
our implementation of your favorite
random variable or you there's a new one
some you know angular random variable
distribution that you want it's actually
pretty easy to add your own all you have
to do is be able to code your own log
probability function and you're in
business so here is the here's a manual
version of the Uniform log probability
right it just takes some value between
some lower and upper bound and returns
you just go to Wikipedia and look up
what the probability distribution
function is and you code it up that's
what it does I'm returning negative
infinity if it's outside the bounds and
then I wrap that in a density dist
object which as the name implies is a
density distribution where the log P is
your log probability function and having
done that I can go do all of the things
that I would do if I as if I were using
one that came with PI MC and it's
uniform so the value is always going to
be the same right so what uniform means
equal probability but if I give it a
negative number in this case I'd get my
negative in which is undefined cool the
only things you have to be aware of is
that once you get into designing your
own probability distributions you have
to know a little bit of theano
it requires you using Theano functions
the switch statement in here notice I
use the switch method rather than a
Python if-else and that's because that's
a Theano function I've we've
encapsulated a lot of them in our PI and
c3 math module so that they're at your
fingertips but you want to be able to
code in a little bit in Theano okay the
one slight variation on this is what
you have a random variable that isn't
free to vary ie one that you've observed
right so what's the difference between a
normal prior and a normal likelihood
well there's no difference really except
for the fact that you've observed one
and you haven't observed the other so we
have what's called an observed RV class
so they're exactly the same I input a
poison in this case the only difference
is I use this observed argument to pass
the data and that essentially fixes it
at that point so that is no longer free
to vary so when when the MCMC sampler
comes along it skips over you because
your value is already known and again if
I wanted to do one by hand so here's a
good example if you're anybody to build
survival models survival likelihoods are
slightly more complicated because they
have to deal with censoring and so this
is an exponential survival function
accounting for censoring encoded as a PI
MC likelihood and you can see has two
unknowns failure and value so they're
just the same they just have to have
this observed value associated with them
so now we've ways of doing stochastic
random variables and observed random
variables the next thing are
deterministic so deterministic variables
are the definition here are ones that
are completely determined by their
parents that is their arguments so it's
a little bit confusing right because if
you have a deterministic value in your
model and you look at the output from
your PI MC run you'll get a distribution
for that right like the you know the log
of something but all of that uncertainty
all of that entire distribution is based
on uncertainty that was inherited from
its arguments and it didn't add any
itself right so completely determined by
parents is really what what is going on
here so we have this deterministic class
here and all you do is it's just a
wrapper for some deterministic
transformation in our case the rates are
what we need so it's got to be a switch
statement if it's before this change
point which is unknown it's one value
otherwise it's another so here's the
switch statement
and and there are two ways of doing that
if you're not interested in the values
themselves summarizing them as part of
the posterior distribution you can do
what we call anonymous deterministic s--
these are easier to write but they won't
be tallied as the algorithm runs there's
essentially intermediate values that
you're throwing away and that's the case
here we don't need all 111 copies of two
different values right we just want the
original rates and the change point so
that's the nice thing here is we don't
need to wrap it if we're not interested
in it
otherwise we want named values so we
just give it a name if it's got a name
time C we'll keep track of it and you
can always go in and look at what the
named variables are and you can see here
that rate is in here but this one that I
did up here that I skipped over mean of
means is not because it's an anonymous
you can do as many of these
deterministic as you want it doesn't
affect your model right because it's
just transforming something it's no cost
to it essentially the third piece here
is what we call factor potentials these
don't get used quite as much if you
don't know about factor potentials you
can you probably do most of what you
need to do but occasionally you need to
add something to a model it doesn't
quite fit as a stochastic are
deterministic and these are typically in
the form of constraints these are
arbitrary log probability terms that we
add into the model one that's might be
relevant here although in strictly
speaking we don't need it for this
problem is what if we want to make sure
that the late mean is smaller than the
early mean right well if we know that a
priori
we can do that with a factor potential
and you see it's not quite a you know
it's not a random variable right and
it's not data
really it's just a constraint and this
could take a variety of forms so
essentially if we're writing it down
it's like this it's the
it's a indicator function of you know
the difference probably shouldn't be
absolute value there that's not right
lambda 1 minus lambda 2 greater than
zero and factor potentials are created
using the potential object so all you do
is you pass the potential in here and
then the statement now is not a
calculated value like a transformation
is this is a log probability so that's
the difference here okay all right so
those are all the pieces that we need to
build the model how do we do our MCMC
now we we call the sample function and
that again it's a high-level package and
the advantage of that is that it will
make reasonable choices on your behalf
but it's easy to customize when it
doesn't so that the sample function
hides a lot of complexity the things
that you're most interested in is number
of drawers how many samples do you want
if you pass it nothing you can pass no
arguments to sample if you want and if
you do you'll get 500 drawers with 500
tuning steps usually not enough for me
but sometimes it is step implies a step
method or an MCMC algorithm it will do
its best to try to pick an appropriate
MCMC algorithm but you're absolutely
entitled to go in and override it with
your favorite information about
initialization we can specify the number
of chains we want so running an MCMC
chain is easy to parallel eyes it's
embarrassingly parallel so you can run a
number of them in parallel at once by
default in fact it will give you however
how many or however many cores you have
divided by two but you can override that
if you want to random seeds for if you
want reproducible because this is a
random number generator if you want to
be able to exactly reproduce things you
can provide a random seed if you want to
okay so like I said assigning step
methods you
to instantiate the MCMC algorithm that
you want so if you want metropolis you
can pass it you can specify different
algorithm CMC algorithms to different
variables in your model it's perfectly
happy to do slice sampling in one place
a metropolis in another an agency in
another whether or not it's valid in
terms of getting you good results is
another question but it will let you do
it if you don't tell it what to do this
is typically what will happen if your
variable is binary true/false 0 1 we
have a binary metropolis you can imagine
it's not very efficient to use a regular
metropolis algorithm with binary
variables so the binary metropolis just
proposes zeros and ones nothing but
discrete values were assigned to
metropolis it will know that it's it'll
look at the D type of the variable and
only propose discrete values otherwise
it will be assigned to this nuts
algorithm that I'm going to talk about
in a second which is an auto-tuned
version of hamiltonian monte carlo
essentially so all those choices we had
to make before about leapfrog step size
and when to stop those sorts of things
ok starting values how do we pick
starting values if you don't pass any
information to your model it will choose
usually the mean the mode or the median
in some cases what you can do is you can
do a optimization so there's a function
called find map which finds the maximum
a-posteriori value for that variable so
it does just use a supplies optimizers
actually and finds the most so you get
posterior modes which usually isn't
enough for inference because there's no
uncertainty but you can use that as a
starting point it's not a good thing to
do if you're doing hamiltonian monte
carlo though in fact we now issue a
warning find map should not be used to
initialize the nuts that sampler because
of that problem I told you before then
the mode for large models is not a good
place to be because there's
much probability there but for small
models it works just fine like this one
here okay so you can always just give it
some values and it will start at those
values and then your samples when you're
finished sampling it sample returns an
object called a multi trace which stores
the trace or the set of sample values
from each of the variables in the model
hence the name multi trace so it tells
you here that I sampled two chains five
hundred iterations each six variables so
it's two by five hundred by six in size
by default those are just given to you
as numpy arrays but you can specify a
sequel light back end or a text back end
that will write them that will serialize
them for you so if we do trace equals
sequel light yeah it will actually slow
things down a little bit one of the best
things to do these days though if you
want to serialize your output is employ
a package called RV's which is sort of a
spin-off project from PI mc3 it's it was
created by some of our developers it
provides an object called an inference
data object which keeps your trace
information on your on the sampling run
itself that can be used for Diagnostics
posterior predictive values and so on
and if you've got that you can save it
as a net CDF and then at a later time if
you need to reload it and it's the same
thing okay so otherwise you know unless
you have so many samples with so many
variables that you're gonna run you know
run out of memory during sampling it's
probably best to do things these ways
with with hamiltonian monte carlo you
don't actually have to take that many
samples because you get a relatively
uncorrelated sample your effective
sample size is quite high if you're
using metropolis you often have to get
tens or hundreds of thousands of samples
because of autocorrelation I already
mentioned parallel sampling you can
specify the number of chains you want
and the number of cores so this will
split chains equal 4 cores equals 2 will
essentially run two chains on each core
and then it returns basically n by C
samples
I'm not sure why this one's running so
slow probably because I'm on a
Chromebook and if you're doing multiple
chains and you want to assign different
values to each of those chains you can
pass a list of dictionaries with those
values so if I want to give a a prior
value of 0.1 to the early mean on one
chain and 10 for the early mean on the
other I can do that I'm gonna stop this
one up here
and we typically want more than one
chain and that's why we do parallel by
defaults namely when we're doing
convergence Diagnostics some of the
Diagnostics will rely on having more
than one chain because it will compare
the values between chains in order to
see if that if your model is converged
or not set methods again these are the
MCMC algorithms that are included with
PMC so Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is is one
of them nuts is is sort of the default
sampler for continuous variables so what
nuts does is that it automatically Tunes
your step size and step number on the
fly so not stance for the no u-turn
sampler so what happens if you follow
the Hamiltonian trajectory what's gonna
happen if you're on you know one side of
your skateboard park and you're and you
run down the hill and up the other side
what happens when you get to the top you
start turning back upon yourself and so
it detects essentially when I you turns
about to occur and then it will stop
because backtracking is going to be
inefficient and the reason the way that
it does that is it employs this binary
doubling so it builds binary trees and
when those trees start to curve back on
themselves that's where it where it
stops essentially so this is kind of the
idea here is that it will sample until
it starts curving back until those make
a perpendicular angle and then it will
sample randomly from this chain to get a
valid point so you don't have to do any
manual tuning of step size or or path
length let's see here I'm yeah
metropolis is in here
binary metropolis as I mentioned only
proposes zeros and ones there's another
sampler that's quite nice for univariate
continuous variables which is a slice
sampler also created by Radford Neil it
sometimes works quite well when
metropolis is inefficient as well but
most of the time we're going to be using
not
alright I've got 15 minutes left which
is probably enough to do the last piece
here model checking clean up some tabs
okay so yeah model checking is very
important
like I said particularly with a
high-level package it's very easy to get
a result that looks sensible but may not
actually be valid due to a any number of
reasons
and it generally breaks down into two
components one is convergence
Diagnostics and the other is
goodness-of-fit convergence Diagnostics
essentially evaluates whether your MCMC
algorithm worked as expected so has your
model converged so the guarantee that
you get remember bet and remember back
when I talked about having a reversible
Markov chain that follows detail balance
if that's the case you're guaranteed to
converge as n goes to infinity well we
don't actually sample infinity right we
stop at some point and we want to know
is it good is a thousand good enough is
10,000 good enough when do we stop and
unfortunately there isn't a universal
answer for that and so you have to do
diagnostics and the Diagnostics that we
do our statistical diagnostics you can't
sort of analytically look at a model and
a sampler and come up with an estimate
of how many samples it's going to take
what we do instead is we use heuristics
to look at the sampler and look for
essentially evidence we sort of do a an
autopsy on it and and see if there's any
evidence for lack of convergence right
so it's sort of like no hypotheses you
can't accept them you can only reject
them if there's evidence to reject them
the same thing goes with convergence
Diagnostics here and again if you've got
a simple model with two or three
parameters convergence usually happens
very quickly it's when you get into
dozens or hundreds of variables and then
it's it's a little bit more challenging
as sort of my final example I'm going to
use a
growth model this is a little bit more
complicated so these are a set of 30 30
rats measured weighed at one-week
intervals starting at week eight so
there's eight fifteen twenty to twenty
nine thirty six and we essentially
modeled the growth curve essentially and
so they kind of look like this and so
I'm just gonna fit a linear model here
but I'm gonna use a hierarchical model
this is one of the motivations for doing
Bayesian analysis is it makes
hierarchical models really easy to do
what do I mean by hierarchical I mean
that the parameters themselves have
their own models right so what we're
gonna do is rather than just say there's
one growth rate or one intercept to the
model we're gonna say that there's a
population of them and each rat rather
than having either a single value or
entirely independent values we're gonna
say that they're drawn from a population
of rat weights and rat growth growth
rates sorry rat weights and rat growth
rates to kind of model this variation
okay so the model looks like this it'll
be the weight is a linear model but you
notice that alphas and the beta's are
subscript adhere so each each rat's
intercept and slope is drawn from a
normal distribution with some population
mean and standard deviation for both
okay all right so here's our here's the
model there are the hierarchical means
there the hierarchical standard
deviations and now you can see these
normals aren't priors these are models
of the variation in initial weight and
growth rate and then we calculate an
expected value so each rat gets its own
values indexed and then our likelihood
function is normal a nice a cool feature
of Pi mc3 is that you can actually print
out the model itself in the form of a
directed acyclic graph so all Bayesian
models can be expressed as directed
acyclic graphs so this shows you know
your data is shaded in gray it's an
observed stochastic all the other ovals
are stochastic
and then it's got these plates showing
that there are 150 data points high
slack and 30 rats so you can kind of
quickly validate whether or not your
model is specified as you expected it if
you've got some node that's floating off
into space you've made a mistake
somewhere all right we're gonna run this
model we're gonna start looking at some
of the output while this is running I'll
start talking about them so there are a
range of ways of doing this the the
first step is always just look at look
at the output just like the first step
in any data analysis is just look at the
data plot the data you want to inspect
your traces and your histograms plotting
them and so this is where the RV's
package comes into play so IMC has a lot
of of diagnostic and plotting functions
but a lot of them have been spun out
into RVs and in fact now we just call
RVs from PI MC so here we go so these
are the myths of the means for the slope
and standard deviation and you know we
have a nice relatively homogeneous trace
it's not it's not trending in any way
the variation isn't changing over time
and we have nice neat symmetric KT ease
for the histograms over here as well so
always the first step just look see what
it looks like I'm gonna intentionally
create some some ugly ones here so you
can sabotage your MCMC runs by giving it
really bad starting values and really
bad samplers so here I'm gonna start the
mean at a thousand intercept at a
thousand and the mean slope at negative
ten and when you do that you get you
know stuff like this and so you can see
when the if two chains and they're not
doing exactly the same thing that's a
problem we have a little bit hard to see
sorry but you when you get any of that
any of those diagnostic patterns that we
saw when I was demonstrating metropolis
Hastings either the
sneaking around the parameter space or
long periods of rejection that's also
going to be gonna be bad and in fact one
of the ways that you can help diagnose
this stuff is to deliberately start
separate chains at varying starting
positions and what you're looking for is
orga disa T it has an erotic behavior
where it will regardless of where you
start it will eventually find its way to
the same spot so that's a good sign
there and the these would be tuning
steps samples that you would throw away
anyhow there are a few formal methods
for it doing Diagnostics one of the key
ones is the Gelman rubin diagnostic and
what this does essentially is a
formalized way of this what it does is
essentially an analysis of variance of
several chains and the idea is that if a
model is converged the variation between
chains should be about the same as the
variation within chains you shouldn't
really be able to tell them apart early
on in the sampling here you can see the
between chain variance is much higher
than the within chain so it calculates
this factor called the potential scale
reduction factor this guy here so it's
the essentially the ratio of the overall
variance over the within chain variance
and over time the between chain variance
should go away so as n gets large and
being the number of samples this goes
away and it's just W versus so those
should be approximately one so you're
looking for they call our hat values of
near one and so you can calculate that
pull in the R hat from our V's and
calculate them you can see in here most
of these are around one you start
worrying if it's you know 0.8 or less
something like that and in fact if you
plot some of the so there's a forest
plot plot forest function they're really
good for visualizing posteriors of
lots of variables in the same figure so
these are posterior plots of the
standard deviation of the and standard
deviation of the slope and intercept and
if you say our hat equals true it will
plot the our hat values for you okay and
you can see both of these are close to
one okay autocorrelation is another nice
diagnostic autocorrelation isn't always
a huge deal you can expect some
autocorrelation because these are after
all Markov chains they're dependent
samples but you do want to minimize it
because what it will do is essentially
reduce if you have a high level of
autocorrelation it reduces the
independence between draws and
essentially your effective sample size
goes down so you have to draw more
samples to get the same level of
precision from your estimates so you can
plot an autocorrelation function to look
at this so these are two plots of MA and
actually same plot of MA one for each
chain and you can see here the each each
value on the X is a lag so the first
notch is the lag between one step lag a
two step lag and so so on all the way
out to a hundred and so it should look
like this sort of random small amounts
of random variation what you're looking
to avoid are things like this so you
here we have particular in the second
chain a high level of autocorrelation
all the way up to you know lag 20 or 30
and it typically means you got to Reaper
ammeter eyes your model you don't have a
very efficient parameterization or
better tune your model and and yeah the
main consequence to this is that you
will have a lower effective sample size
so here's effective sample size which is
a function of the number of drawers that
you take and the number of chains but
you can see here's the autocorrelation
summed over all of the lags and if
that's really high it lowers the
effective sample size and you can
similarly plot make a forest plot with
ESS equals true so effective sample size
equals true and it will plot ESS instead
of our hat
so in this case I drew 2,000 samples
after burnin and you can see for these
two parameters it was pretty close to
2,000 but for the standard deviation it
was had an effective sample size that
was about only about half so we didn't
have some autocorrelation there's a
temptation if you read some early MCMC
literature and certainly papers people
published they'll thin their sample
they'll just take every tenth draw but
there's really no point in doing that
because you're what are you doing there
you're reducing your sample size by a
factor of 10 or whatever so just leave
it alone and show your autocorrelation
the effect will be the same so I've only
got a couple minutes left the only
section that I haven't been able to get
to is the gradient based sampler
Diagnostics I'll just let you do that
you know on your own it's just a
different set of Diagnostics that uses a
little bit more information because of
the fact that we had gradient
information so you can actually do a
better job of diagnosing gradient based
sampling than just metropolis Hastings
and yeah so I'll stop there and I
probably have two or three minutes left
for questions and I'm happy to answer
everyone's questions during the weekend
if you can track me down so let's wrap
it up there thanks a lot for attending
and hanging in for the whole hour and a
half
[Applause]
maybe one one question one or two yeah
what is tres no no it isn't so the
question was what is a trace a trace is
just MC MC lingo for the sample so it's
the it's the time series of sampled
values and it's just called a trace yeah
it's not the same as the trace of a
matrix absolutely thanks for clarifying
well so the question had to do how do
you make the transition from dealing
with classical statistics namely
likelihoods into bayes machine learning
oh I see so maximization right so here
the benefit you're getting is dealing
with uncertainty and you're getting
probabilistic on a probabilistic
approach the cost to that is specifying
priors right so that's really the only
difference right as you specify priors
for your unknowns and that allows you to
get probabilities in and probabilities
out and that's the thing that you could
be kind of have to it's more of the art
right you learn what priors tend to work
and which ones don't and so it just it
often takes practice but you know the
guideline is to you know understand what
your variables are what values they can
take and and sort of practice so you
know you can make Bayesian versions of
traditional machine learning models
right there's Bayesian neural networks
and what is that that's just putting
priors on the weights between the layers
and so you there's actually a nice
example in the pmc repository of a
Bayesian neural networks and so looking
at models like that that are just
Bayesian versions of things you're
familiar with be the best way to get
started all right thanks everybody
[Applause]